is there room for free will
in this
uh
in us in this view of the universe is
generating novelty and getting greater
and greater assembly
uh structures
built sarah
yes
okay
done
next question
why what's the source of free will in
this well so i i think it depends on
what you mean by free will um
but
yeah well please
i think i think what i'm interested in
as far as the
phenomena of free will is
uh do we have
individual autonomy and agency
and you know when i do things is it
really me or is it my atoms that did it
um and
that's the part that's interesting to me
i guess there's also the determinism
versus randomness part
um but the way i think about it is like
each of us are
like a thread
or like an you know assembly space
through
you know this this giant possibility
space and it's like we're moving
on our own trajectory through that space
and that is defined by our history so
we're sort of causally contingent on our
past
but also because of the
sort of intersection of
novelty generation it's not completely
predetermined by the past
and so so then you have the causal
control
of the determinism part that you are
your causal history and there's some
determinism from that past but there's
also
room for creativity and i think it's
actually
necessary that something like free will
exists if the universe is going to be as
creative as possible because
if i were
all intelligent being inventing a
universe
and i wanted it to have
maximal number of interesting things
happen again we should come up with the
metric of interesting
but
generating yes i know
generating um you know maximal
possibilities then i would want the
agents to have free will because it
means that
their individual like they like each
entity actually is a different causal
force in the universe
and it's intrinsic and local property of
that system
there's a greater number of distributed
agents
are you always creating more and more
individuality
kind of
i i would say you're creating more
causal power but
the causal power
the word consciousness is is the cause
of power somehow correlated with
consciousness i mean that that's why i
have this conception of consciousness
being related to imagination because the
more that we can imagine can happen and
the more counterfactual possibilities
you have in mind the more you can
actually implement and somehow free will
is also at the intersection of the
counter factual becoming the actual
um so can you elaborate on that a little
bit that consciousness is imagination i
don't know exactly how to articulate it
and i'm sure people take
you know aim at certain things i'm
saying but i think the language is
really imprecise so i'm not the best way
to really it's really interesting like
what is imagination and what is it uh
what role does it play
in the human experience in experience of
any yeah
i love imagination i think it's like the
most amazing uh thing we do but i guess
one way i would think about it is we
talked about the transition to life
being the universe acquiring memory and
life does something really interesting
just think about biology generally it
remembers states of the past to adapt to
things that happen in the future so so
the longer life has evolved on this
planet the deeper that past is the more
memory we have the more kinds of
organisms and things but
what human level intelligence has done
is quite different it's not just that we
remember states that the universe has
existed in before it's that we can
imagine ones that have never existed and
we can actually make them come into
existence and i think that's the most
unique feature about the transition to
whatever we are from what life on this
planet has been doing for the last four
billion years
and i think it's deeply related to the
phenomena we call consciousness yeah i
was going to i mean just agree with that
i think that consciousness is the
ability to generate those counter
factuals now whether you can say you
know are there degrees of consciousness
i mean
and i mean
i mean i'm i'm sorry
pansys but electrons don't have
counterfactuals although they do have
some kind of they are able to search the
space and pathways but but i think that
there is a very
concrete
concrete there's a very specific
property that humans have and i'm and i
don't know if it's unique to humans i
mean maybe dogs can do it and and and
birds can do it right and where they are
basically solving a problem because
consciousness was invented or this
abstraction was invented by evolution
for that for a specific reason
um and so look the
one of the reasons why i came to the
conclusion that time was fundamental it
was actually because
sarah and i had
completely different the most heated
debate on skype chat ever no no no
no i no it goes back to the free will
thing so i i think that although i've
changed my view a bit because there's
some really interesting physicists out
there who talks about
how the measurement problem
in in in newtonian space but i don't
want to go there just now because i
think i'll mess it up but
briefly
um i could not see how the universe how
we can have free will and i mean this is
really boring because like this is like
this is a well trodden path but
but
it's not so boring i suppose it's kind
of we just want to be precise
if the universe is deterministic how can
we have free will right so
uh sarah's a physicist
i think she believe and not believe can
show that the most of the laws we have
are deterministic to some degree quantum
mechanics onto newtonian stuff and yet
there's sarah telling me she believes in
free will i'm like
your belief system is broken here right
because you you're demanding free will
in a deterministic universe
and and then i've
realized that i i agreed with her that i
do think that free will is a thing
because we were able to search for
novelty and then that's where i came to
the conclusion that time the universe
was expanding in terms of novelty and it
goes back to that dan dennett essay they
were talking about the the free will
inflation
free will so you are you have so the
past
it did not exist in the past the past
exists in the present what i mean is
like you are the there was no past there
is only present that means you are the
sum total although everything that
occurs in the past is it is manifestly
here in the present
and then you have this little echo state
in your consciousness because you're
able to you're able to imagine something
without actualization but the fact you
imagine it that occurs in electrons and
potassium ion flows in your neural
network in your brain maybe
consciousness is just the present
so so somehow you imagine that
and then by imagining oh that's good
yeah um i'm gonna make a robot do this
thing
and program it and then you physically
then go and do it
so that changes the future sorry
what's imagination
does it require the past does it require
the future does it require memory does
it it's imagination
does it only exist in the moment so
imagination is
yeah probably it's an instantaneous
readout of what's going on you can maybe
your your subconscious brain has been
generating all the all the bits for it
but no imagination occurs
when you
in your game engine you you remember the
past and you integrate sensory the
present and you try and work out what
you want to do in the future
and then you go and make that happen
so the imagination is this is like
imagine asking what imagination is about
asking what surfing is
you can see you can surfboard surfer
wave coming in when you're on that wave
and you're surfing
that's where the imagination is i think
i think imagination is just accessing
things that aren't the present moment in
the present moment so like i can i'm
sitting here and i'm looking at the
table and i can imagine
the river in things or whatever it was
and so it seems to be that it's like
it's our ability to access
things that aren't present but so
conjure up worlds some of them might be
akin to something that happened to you
recently right but they don't have they
don't have to be things that actually
happen in your past and i think this
gets back to assembly theory like the
way i would think about imagination from
an assembly theoretic standpoint is i'm
a giant causal graph
and i exist in a present moment as a
particular configuration of sarah
and
but there's a lot of i carry a lot of
evolutionary baggage i have that whole
causal history and i can
access parts of it now when you talk
about getting to something as complex as
us having as large as assembly space as
us there's ways of
like there's a lot of things in that
causal graph that have ever actually
never existed in the past history of the
universe because like the universe got
big enough to contain
the three of us in this room
in time
but
not all the features of each one of us
individually
have come into existence as physical
objects we would recognize as individual
objects this goes back to your point
that we actually have to explain why why
things
actually even look like objects and
aren't just a smear of
mass
um
and just on the the free will and
physics thing when you were talking i
was i just want to bring this up because
i think it's a really interesting
viewpoint that nicholas jizen has that
um you know like we want to use the laws
of physics and then say you can't have
free will and his point is you have to
have free will in order to even choose
to set up an experiment to test the laws
of physics so in some sense free will
should be more fundamental than physics
is to because to even do science there's
some assumption
that
the agents have free will and i always
thought it was really perplexing that
um
you know physics wants to remove agency
because the idea that i could do an
experiment here in this part of earth
and then i can move somewhere else and
prepare an identically you know
identically prepared experiment run an
experiment again
seems to imply something about the
structure of our universe that is not
encoded in the laws that we're testing
in those experiments
so this kind of dream of physics that
you can do multiple experiments
different locations and then validate
each other
you're saying that's
uh that's an illusion no i'm saying that
requires decision-making and free will
to be a real thing i think
like i think that i think the fact that
we can do science is not arbitrary and i
think people you know the standard canon
in physics would be well you could trace
all of that back to the initial
condition in the universe but the whole
point of science is i can imagine doing
the experiment and i can do it and then
i can do it again and again and again
all over the place to you imagination
somehow fundamentally
generative of novelty yes so it's not
like the universe could have predicted
the things you imagined the imagination
super so coming back to novelty i think
novelty can exist outside of imagination
but it supercharges it it's another
transition i think
i mean i would say
i mean this may be a boring statement
but i would say that's factor sorry i'm
not sure it's a heart these are hard
questions yeah i mean i think the fact
that objects exist is yet another proof
that
that time is fundamental and novelty
exists right
because i think again
if you ask a physicist to write down an
infinite bible of the universe let's
call it the bible the the mac you know
matebook
the mathematical universe whether you're
a max tag mark or sean carroll or frank
wilcheck
[Laughter]
or or stephen wolfram okay yeah i like
that bucket yeah i love it too lots of
pretty pictures
it's really interesting that they they
cope with the enormity of the universe
by saying well it's all their
mathematics it all exists right and and
i would say that
that's why i'm excited about the future
of the universe because it it although
it is somehow dependent upon the past
it is not constrained
just by the past
which is kind of mad
yeah that's what free will is it's not
constrained by the past it's dependent
on the past
this moment it's not just dependent this
moment is the past and yet it has the
capacity to generate a totally
unpredictable future i mean the other
thing i would say is super important for
human beings right human beings have
actually very little causal control in
the future
i realized this the other week
so what happened so this is what i think
it is the way by reinterpreting your
past i mean talk about from a kind of
cognitive psychological cognitive point
of view by reinterpreting your past
in your current mind
you can actually helps you shape your
future again so you but you you have
much more freedom to interpret your past
to act in the present to change your
future than you do to change your future
it may sound weird so i'm saying
everybody imagine your past think about
your past reinterpret your past in the
nicest way you can then imagine what you
can do next or imagine your past in a
more negative way and what you do next
and look at those two counterfactuals
they're different
yeah it's fast i mean daniel conor talks
about this that most of our life is
lived in our memories it's interesting
because you can essentially in
imagination choose the life you live so
maybe free will exist in imagination
choices are made in your imagination
and that results in you basically able
to control how the future unrolls
because you're like
imagining
like reinterpreting constantly the
things that happen to you exactly so
you're there if you want to increase
your amount of free will
those people that have mo i don't think
everyone has equal amounts of agency
because of uh because of our sad sad
constraints whether whether you know
happenstance with health
economic
born born in a certain place right
but
you're those of us that have the ability
to go back and reinterpret our past
and and and use that to change the
future
are the ones that exert most agency in
the present
and i i want to i want to achieve
higher degrees of agency and enable
everyone else to do that as well to have
more fun
in the universe then we'll hit that peak
maximum fun i don't think there's ever
going to be a maximum pop i think it's
the wonderful thing about the future is
always going to be more fun
you